die märkte station ist schwitzt denn
auch diesen sommer resten sprach
liebhaber in die walliser berge zum
internationalen literaturfestival
leukerbad auf dem programm
lesung mit ausblick zum übersetzungs
workshop geladen kinder tot und nora
gomringer beste gelegenheit mit den
beiden poet ihnen zu ergründen was denn
die sprachenvielfalt mit den europäern
macht
ich würde etwas mit der sprache machen
kinopremiere kinder tot übersetzte
gedichte ihrer kollegin auf ungarisch
ist die ältere schwester mit dem anderen
übersetzern haben wir darüber gesprochen
seemann assante ein titel der auf ja im
prinzip den katholizismus verwaist da
hat mir der finnisch übersetzer gesagt
dass das sagt uns gar nichts in finnland
da müssen alle kugeln übersetzerinnen
und übersetzer sind botschafter
vermittler zwischen sprachen und kultur
eine gute handvoll war beim workshop mit
von der partie
denn nicht nur in ungarn und finnland
sollen werke der schweizerisch-deutschen
ingeborg bachmann preisträgerin nora
gomringer eingang finden
vielmals einmal tanzte der bauer so wild
in much dass das kalb sich erschreckte
einmal nämlich rizinus und verlor das
kind sei dabei eine europäische klang
komposition oder wie umberto eco einmal
sagte die sprache europas ist
übersetzung
wer gedichte in eine andere sprache
übersetzt wagt sich hoch hinaus
schnuppert sozusagen dünne luft ist doch
poesie die essenz der gedanken die
kurzform einer geschichte vieles liegt
zwischen den zeilen der
interpretationsspielraum immens in
europa gibt es rund 150 sprachen für die
beiden kultur vermittlerinnen keine
unüberwindbare hürde sondern bloß eine
herausforderung eine aufforderung den
inneren schweinehund zu überwinden
wir europäer müssen sozusagen unsere
flügel ausbreiten
grenzen überwinden und einander
verstehen wollen dass gegenüber
begriffen war die lippen steht ein
gesicht sieht den anderen in kienbaum
und wenn das ausbleibt dann bleibt auch
die begegnung innerhalb europas klaus
und das können wir uns doch gar nicht
leisten
ich werde etwas bitte sprache
mehrsprachig tritt gleich recht tun
jetzt muss die botschaft nur noch gehört
werden ja ich denke wir müssen jetzt
europa wie sagt man das höflich ja
king.de es sie wieder
also wir müssen ein bisschen alt europa
motivieren also ich würde gerne so ein
hut machen
[Musik]